[Musique]
là bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end sur tv 78 de l'actualité des
idées de sorties pour bien terminer la
semaine dans les yvelines voici le
programme de ce 5 novembre
stèle hantise va déployer son campus
vert dédié à l'automobile à poissy
dernière annonce en date qui vient
s'ajouter à d'autres grands projets de
recherche et développement la matière
dans le département le véhicule de
demain se pense et se prépare dans les
yvelines tour d'horizon le début
dimanche de la 15e transat jacques vabre
depuis le havre louis burton sera une
nouvelle fois sur la ligne de départ
avec davy beaudart sur bureau vallée
après sa troisième place au dernier
vendée globe l'yvelinois aura à coeur de
briller sur la route du café qui prend
la direction cette année de la
martinique il est notre invité
et puis comme à chaque fois on vous
donne l'idée de sortir dans le
département notre sélection pour le
week-end dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission
avec bien sûr le retour de bixente mes
ressentis stevans havas bixente très
bien je suis père en tennis y trouve
cette fois mais ça va bien mais tout de
même un menu à nous proposer pour sortir
dans le département exactement après
après halloween la semaine dernière on
se dirige lentement vers sion et
sûrement vers noël et pour cécile ou
patinoire et courses de chiens de
traîneaux rendez vous restez avec nous
c'est tout à l'heure dans le sais tu ce
week-end
l'actualité d'abord avec je vous le
disais dans les titres un campus vert
recherche et développement dans le
milieu automobile qui va se développer à
poissy c'est le groupe stèle hantise qui
l'annoncé le 27 octobre dernier bon jour
mais les nippes ok de la rédaction de tv
78 et c'est un nouveau site qui renforce
l'implantation du monde automobile dans
les yvelines eh oui soixante mille
mètres carrés réunissant la recherche et
le développement mais aussi les
activités tertiaires ce campus
entièrement végétalisée situer donc à
poisy rassemblera en 2024 une partie des
équipes r&d pour le moment basé à vélizy
et l'ensemble des salariés regroupés à
poissy et attrapes ce site ne sera pas
le seul de cet élan tice dans les
yvelines milan saura le plus important
avec plus de 11000 personnes attendues
le groupe stèle en tice est né de la
fusion du groupe psa et de fiat chrysler
automobile mais ce n'est pas le seul
groupe à développer et installer des
sites r&d dans le département renault
vise l'économie circulaire sur son site
de flins sur seine oui à l'horizon 2024
il n'y aura plus de production de
voitures pour le site de renault flins
qui fabrique actuellement la zoé la
voiture électrique en mars 2021 le
groupe présentait le programme station
flins le centre d'innovation de
l'économie régénératrice de la
refactorisation son objectif le
reconditionnement des véhicules
d'occasion la valorisation des pièces
usagées de nouvelles activités liées au
recyclage et la transition bas carbone
de la mobilité renault vise un bilan
carbone négatif à devenir d'ici 2030
avec un lien décidément aussi dans les
yvelines puisque le groupe est
historiquement implanté dans le
département et oui depuis 1998 renault à
son technocentre à guyancourt c'est le
premier centre de recherche et de
développement automobile en europe sur
150 hectares de terrain les équipant ses
programmes des gammes renault bien sûr
mais aussi dacia et renault samsung ce
sont plus de dix mille salariés qui sont
présents sur le centre merci mélanie
pour toutes ces précisions et on aura
l'occasion de donner la parole aux
acteurs indirectement de ce nouveau
dossier qui a été annoncé en ce campus
vert recherche et développement qui va
voir le jour sur le site de poissy nous
mettons le cap à présent au havre où la
15e transat jacques vabre s'apprête à
démarrer la course en duo sans escale ni
assistance au travers de l'atlantique
s'élancera dimanche direction fort de
france en martinique et parmi les 160
skipper sur la ligne de départ un
yvelinois louis burton qui est avec nous
par visioconférence bonjour louis
bonjour à tous merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes à bord de votre bateau
justement à moins de 48 heures de ce
départ et vous êtes engagés pour votre
sixième route du café en catégorie imoca
vous ferez équipe une nouvelle fois avec
davy beaudart sur un nouveau bateau dont
on aura l'occasion de parler dans un
instant comment vous sentez-vous à j
moins de deux secondes et par balle à
l'effervescence était à son maximum les
partenaires les sponsors du projet la
famille touré arrivé donc on essaye de
partager un maximum de temps avec eux et
puis on se prépare à se dire aurevoir de
bain le bateau est prêt toute l'équipe a
fait un super boulot là dans les huit
jours donc on a de partir on va partir
dans des conditions plutôt clémente avec
juste ce qu'il faut comme vent pour
avancer donc voilà très très content et
bien sûr hâte de partir d'ailleurs les
dernières heures d'un skipper en compte
de la mer vous le disais ça ça ressemble
à ça c'est passé du temps avec sa
famille à des dernières choses peut-être
à régler avant le départ ouais des
choses toutes bêtes on doit on doit
passer un supermarché tout à l'heure
pour pour faire le complément pour nos
courses demain un peu au dernier moment
on va acheter du frais des tomates des
oranges des choses comme ça voilà donc
là on est vraiment plus que sur les
petits détails mais qui ont leur
importance parce que il faut il faut
pouvoir s'alimenter correctement et ce
sera votre sixième participation depuis
2011 une deuxième fois d'affilée avec
votre ami à davy beaudart avec qui vous
avez obtenu une c'était une septième
place une dixième place pardon sur
l'édition 2019 pourquoi repartir avec
lui finalement qu'est ce qui fait votre
complémentarité
alors débit c'est un très très bon
technicien il a une vingtaine d'années
d'expérience dans la préparation de
bateaux de course donc voilà il a un
bagage techno supérieur au mien et donc
il a pris en charge toute cette partie
là avec l'équipe et puis moi j'ai plus
de temps du coup pour me concentrer sur
la stratégie passer du temps avec les
partenaires et on est donc très
complémentaires sur la préparation puis
ensuite c'est c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
beaucoup de courses aussi qui a gagné
beaucoup de des preuves
notre classe qui s'appelle la classe
mini donc on est deux solitaires qui
partons sur sur ce nouveau bateau bureau
vallée donc quand il y en a un qui est
sur le pont l'autre se reposer sur un
peu sereinement parce qu'il sait que
celui qui est dehors et au taquet et
sait faire marcher un bateau tout seul
donc voilà c'est complémentarité et par
des différences de profil et aussi par
une approche assez commune de ski la
course cela par rapport au dernier
vendée globe que vous avez clôturer une
belle troisième place la course est
beaucoup plus courte elle se déroule
cette fois-ci en duo est ce que ça
change la donne est ce que l'expérience
du vendée globe va vous servir justement
sur cette transat
l'extérieur du vendée globe ça sert
toujours forcément il ya une partie du
parcours qui qui se ressemblent toutes
la première partie jusqu'à l'équateur et
même jusqu'à faire nono devant le brésil
c'est c'est très proche du vendée globe
donc c'est bien d'avoir encore ses
souvenirs là en tête après c'est très
différent dans le sens où là c'est un
sprint qui va durer une quinzaine de
jours
donc il faut tout de suite rentré dans
un rythme très soutenu pour pas se faire
décrocher pas les bateaux de tête et on
est dans un rythme où on est en double
donc on mène la machine à 100% tout le
temps on est plutôt sur des notions de
remplir ans sur une course comme le
vendée globe et pour la première fois
d'ailleurs la course transatlantique ira
non pas salvador de bahia au brésil mais
jusqu'en martinique alors il ya des
passages classique qui reste en vous en
avez parlé le début de la course avec
passage de la manche le golfe de
gascogne le pot-au-noir comment vous
l'appréhendez justement ce nouveau
parcours
bah c'est super de changer un peu sur
les schémas tidiane jacques vabre et
tarica et heritage ayew président puis à
salvador c'est sympa d'aller dans une
autre destination les antilles
françaises c'est magnifique en plus et
puis ça fait tout un tout un parcours
toute une tranche du parcours qui
correspond pas à ce qu'on a l'habitude
de faire donc entre le nord du brésil et
puis la martinique car il va falloir
repasser l'équateur le pot-au-noir donc
voilà c'est très excitant d'aller
découvrir ce nouveau tronçon on voit
effectivement à l'image et avec un
nouveau bateau sur lequel vous naviguez
depuis quelques mois bureau vallée 3
vous l'avez depuis la fin du dernier
vendée globe vous avez changé après
justement ce vendée globe que vous avez
clôturer la troisième place vous avez pu
faire quelques courses aborde ce nouveau
bateau quelles sont les sensations
gros potentiel de vitesse
d'un bateau qui va qui va très vite à
toutes les allures donc voilà on est on
est très satisfait de ce choix après on
a encore atteint un stade supérieur aux
niveaux au niveau de la vitesse et donc
des chocs dans la mer donc c'est très
éprouvant et il faut être en pleine
forme on a travaillé sur l'ergonomie à
mort pour essayer de débats de souffrir
un peu moins de tous les chocs comprend
en permanence dans ce bateau qui est
quand même une caisse de résonance en
carbone pour les non initiés à la voile
qu'est-ce qui change concrètement entre
ce nouveau bateau et le bateau sur
lequel vous avez terminé à une troisième
place au vendée globe
le la taille des foils les folles ce
sont ces appendices sur les côtés du
bateau qui ressemble un petit peu a des
ailes et c'est même principe qu'une aile
d'avion avec un intra d'autres
l'extrados c'est l'eau s'écoule de part
et d'autre et ça fait décoller la coque
sur le précédent bateau bureau vallée
ces appendices était petit et la bombe à
une énorme surface donc sabato qui va
décoller plus tôt et qui va voler plus
gros qui va être capable du coup d'aller
encore plus vite en diminuant la surface
mouillée donc la surface traîner une
dernière question lui burton le plateau
de cette 15e édition est très relevé en
catégorie imoca il y aura le dernier
vainqueur du vendée globe et yannick
bestaven y aura aussi les derniers
vainqueurs de la transat charlie dalin
et yann eliès qui seront également là
mais sur deux équipages différents votre
meilleur résultat on le rappelle c'était
une cinquième place obtenue en 2013 du
coup l'objectif c'est de faire aussi
bien peut-être mieux sur cette transat
way l'objectif c'est de rentrer dans le
top 5 on a un bateau qui nous permet
d'aller chercher mieux mais on n'a pas
encore énormément d'expérience sur ce
bateau par rapport aux concurrents que
vous avez cités là notamment et et puis
d'autres comme charal qu'ils ont des
bateaux de dernière génération mais
depuis pas mal de temps qu'on fait le
vendée globe avec voilà donc on a on a
une concurrence à un plateau très relevé
et vous serez donc au départ de ce
bateau dimanche 1 sur votre 10e transat
jacques vabre aux côtés de davy beaudart
sur bureau vallée trois bonnes chances
oui merci d'avoir été avec nous on
suivra bien sur cette course avec
attention la deuxième semaine des
vacances de la toussaint se termine
bientôt peut-être que vous n'étiez pas
dans les yvelines ces derniers jours pas
de panique mathilde francou vous résume
l'actualité de la semaine et c'est ton
78 secondes
la ministre de la transition écologique
barbara pompili s'est rendu à trappes
dans l'un des entrepôts de l'entreprise
métro le site est équipé de panneaux
photovoltaïques depuis 2019 ces derniers
seront bientôt obligatoire cela fait
partie des dix mesures annoncées par la
ministre de la transition écologique
pour le développement du photovoltaïque
le méga centres de vaccination au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
réduit ses effectifs il passe d'environ
3000 vaccinations par jour à 300 ce
nouveau mini centre composé de trois
boxes avec deux médecins et une
infirmière est ouvert du lundi au
vendredi de 9h à 15h la trêve hivernale
a commencé une période durant laquelle
les locataires ne peuvent pas être
expulsés de leur logement jusqu'au 31
mars 2022 cependant les personnes
concernées par cette trêve doivent tout
de même payer une indemnité qui équivaut
au montant du loyer et des charges un
nouveau pôle périnatale ouvre ses portes
au dessus de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines au total quatorze
professionnels seront présents pour
répondre aux besoins de la femme
enceinte et des enfants jusqu'à l'âge de
1 an enfin l'open de france est de
retour au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une reprise
attendue suite aux annulations de ces
deux dernières années à cause du colis
de 19 le tournoi se disputera du 22 au
25 septembre 2022
[Musique]
et puis votre rubrique légal checking
pour vérifier ce que disent les acteurs
de l'actualité dans son couronne du
collectif des surligneurs décrypte
aujourd'hui une proposition de la
candidate socialiste à la présidentielle
anne hidalgo celle de déployer un
service public de la petite enfance
l'insuffisance du nombre de places en
crèches en france est criante cela
entrave l'accès au travail pour les
femmes notamment et c'est ce qui a
conduit anne hidalgo candidate
socialiste à la présidence de la
république à promettre de créer si elle
est élue un service public de la petite
enfance crèches municipales ou crèches
privées l'offre en effet ne couvre que
partiellement les besoins et les parents
doivent recourir aux assistances
maternelles système bien plus coûteux et
subventionné par la caisse d'allocations
familiales
face à cette offre très bigarré la
réponse consistant à créer un service
public de la petite enfance n'est pas en
soi critiquable juridiquement reste que
dit comme cela c'est insuffisant et cela
ne renseignent pas sur les implications
juridiques pourquoi parce qu'un service
public national et bien il est géré par
l'état qui en assume donc les dépenses
alors que jusque là les communes étaient
seules mises à contribution cela
signifie que l'état reprendra sous son
giron les crèches existantes et surtout
qu'il s'engage à en créer d'autres
autant qu'il en faudra car service
public national signifie aussi égalité
devant le service toute personne devra
avoir accès à ce service public où
qu'elles se trouvent sur le territoire
et un coût raisonnable il faudra donc
déployer un réseau de crèches là où
actuellement il en manque et puis aussi
qu'adviendra-t-il des 1900 crèches
privées déjà existantes et mais aussi
des crèches associatives
ces crèches sous contrat serait donc
subventionné par l'état de façon à en
déduire le camp réduire le coût pour les
parents et comme pour les écoles aussi
il y aurait des crèches hors contrat des
crèches de luxe ou alors très marqué sur
le plan idéologique ou religieux on le
voit cette promesse lancée par la
candidate socialiste nécessite d'être
précisé
car ses implications bien au-delà de la
seule ouverture de nouvelles crèches
allez c'est l'heure d'enfiler son
manteau pour sortir ce week-end dans les
yvelines
avec bien sûr la sélection de bixente
mais rien senti steban de retour en
plateau et bixente avec le manteau on va
enfiler les patins à glace pour
commencer will gregory la patinoire de
mantes la jolie est enfin ouverte depuis
ce mardi 2 novembre après une fuite de
glycol ayant empêché sa remise en glace
pendant près d'un mois elle est prête à
accueillir les familles les jeunes et
moins jeunes de menthe ou d'ailleurs une
activité toujours apprécié des yvelinois
reportage
nous on habite à une demi heure c'est
moins qu'une heure toute façon puisque
seuls des yvelines donc pour nous et
dégoûtant encore déguisé aux couleurs
d'halloween la seule patinoire des
yvelines a rouvert ses portes ce mardi 2
novembre à mantes-la-jolie la reine est
déjà très prisé des bâtiments ya un
engouement donc on a pas mal de monde
sur site et puis on est on est
agréablement surpris par cette clientèle
au rendez vous et qui est je pense très
heureuse de nous retrouver comme nous on
est très heureux d'y retrouver aussi moi
ça faisait quelques années que j'en
faisais pas je regardais plutôt mes
enfants faire et puis là aujourd'hui je
me suis dit allez on va retenter on a
prévu même revenir ce week end je
penserai en soirée parce que c'est vous
encore plus sympa quand on avec ses
potes tout même
pour tout seul c'est amusant de vous sur
la glace tous les niveaux sont présents
cela va du petit glisseurs aux
freestylers plus expérimentés
[Musique]
l'esta fille s'entraîne ici depuis plus
de dix ans c'est un atout pour nous les
qui les jeunes qui sont issus de la
ville pense que c'est déjà une structure
en plus parce qu'on en a pas beaucoup de
choses on va dire la vérité dans cette
ville là on en voit beaucoup de
structures pour pouvoir s'évader et
sortir un peu du quartier donc ça nous a
permis aussi à moi jeunes issus de
banlieues aussi de sortir de ce cadre là
de pouvoir m'extérioriser grâce à la
patinoire et c'est devenu une passion un
plaisir une escapade pour laquelle de
nombreux yvelinois se sont laissés
tenter on a des publics qui n'ont pas la
possibilité d'aller faire du ski donc
c'est une activité
voilà qui permet de s'éclater sur la
glace donc des moments de glisse pour
tout le monde après les vacances
scolaires la patinoire sera ouverte les
mardi et vendredi midi les mercredis et
samedis après midi et en nocturne le
vendredi
vous avez un fils et vos patins aussi
vous détestez cette patinoire gc leye
j'allais pas aussi vite que même les
enfants de 6 ans j'allais même moins
vite que moi j'espère vous avez été
prudents et l'heure de votre invité dans
la partie loisirs bixente c'est une
activité dont on avait commencé à parler
déjà la semaine dernière en effet grippe
a on avait parlé de cette activité
insolite ce week-end en forêt de sainte
apolline à plaisir de nombreuses courses
de chiens de traîneaux sont organisés on
avec nous michel boutin ancien président
du club de poule k et de traîneaux à
chiens d'ile-de-france et commissaires
de piste pour ce week-end bonjour
pour rentrer dans le sujet grégory vous
êtes renseignez vous sur ce qu'était une
course de chiens de traîneaux bien sûr
tout d'abord le nord de chiens on
l'appelle le musher ensuite c'est une
compétition où le chien tire un attelage
et ses attelages peuvent être variés on
pense souvent au traîneau sur neige
bixente mais dans le cas des courses de
ce week-end les chiens tracteront des
vélos des trottinettes ou encore des
cartes comme toutes les courses l'équipe
qui finit le plus vite l'emportent mais
effectivement et monsieur boutin du coup
comment ça va se dérouler sur plaisir
combien de courson sont prévues
alors demain c'est à dire samedi et
dimanche d'un tapis les départs seront
mois d'août berton et à une verve bayadh
le parcours
justement pour les tracés des courses y
en a il ya deux parcours comme il disait
comment est il était décidé c'est ça
traverse toute la forêt
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
le déjanté démonter parcours il y aura 8
km
pour les seniors et pour les enfants
iront à 2km d'accord et par rapport à la
discipline on sait que les attelages de
chiens peuvent peuvent les chiens
peuvent traîner atteint jusqu'à 40
km/heure sa demande quelle qualité
d'être méchant vous qui avez été un
piètre mouchard aussi
la qualité il faut être sportif parce
que parfois il faut courir derrière
poussé le cartel pelo et on a des très
bon tiens il faut quand même
courir derrière un peu
pour les spectateurs seulement qui
veulent venir voir ça il ya des endroits
stratégiques où se posait regarder
peut-être l'arrivée par exemple alors
effectivement à l'arrivée
dans veulent mais alors le départ est
encore mué
au départ
allait avoir des
alors on peut
mais quand le parcours laissant les clés
voilà d'accord bas merci beaucoup michel
boutin d'avoir été avec nous pour rappel
vous organisez donc ce week-end samedi 6
et dimanche 7 novembre des courses de
chiens de traîneaux dans la forêt de
sainte apolline près de plaisir 75
attelages sont disponibles pour le
départ des nombreux des nombreuses
courses organisées du coup ces deux
jours oui
il est plus
grande quand on disait voilà des vélos
des kartings
et d'autres sortes de choses puisqu'il
n'y a pas de neige en ce moment grégory
merci pour le travail pmt michel boutant
qui étaient avec nous la connexion un
peu mauvaise puisqu'il était dans cette
forêt de sainte apolline où se déroulera
bien sûr cette ses courses de chiens de
traîneaux ce week-end alors ce week-end
ceci le dernier week-end malheureusement
des vacances de la toussaint mais c'est
la dernière occasion de profiter des
animations dédiées à one nation oui le
centre commercial des clés se voir
organiser à nouveau pendant les vacances
sont safari expédition plusieurs
parcours ont investi les différentes
places du centre la principale c'est le
parcours aventure pour partir à travers
la jungle tel tarzan avec 20 mètres de
parcours d'accrobranche parmi les autres
activités proposées un mur d'escaladé de
six mètres de haut et enfin un parcours
d' équilibre pour les plus petits donc
ça c'est des trois ans des petits
ateliers pour s'amuser travailler sa
motricité de quoi se dégourdir les
jambes finalement au milieu d'une petite
après midi shopping en famille et
grégory tout ça ça accessible donc de
14h à 18h jusqu'à dimanche on va enlever
les patins à glace qu'on avait mis tout
à l'heure pour aller sur la patinoire et
enfiler les chaussures de running
puisque du côté de fontenay le fleury à
la course royal qui fait son retour pour
une huitième édition exactement organisé
par la commune de fontenay les départs
sont lancés dimanche matin de 9 heures à
13 heures en 2019 is étaient environ 800
a participé aux différentes courses au
programme cette fois une course de 10 km
une de 20 km une marche nordique de 10
km également et une spéciale pour les
enfants un peu comme les traîneaux à
chiens finalement de 2 km deux circuits
points forts du tracé comme chaque année
son parcours à travers la plaine de
versailles avec une ligne de départ au
niveau de la biais de la belle pièce
d'eau des suisses un lieu emblématique
notamment pour les joggeurs du coin et
ils passeront ensuite au niveau de la
statue de louis xiv l'allée de
villepreux ou encore le parc du château
un beau parcours en perspective
direction un but cas présent un bixente
pour une première qui méritait d'être
mise en lumière exactement au programme
forum sensibilisation échanges c'était
la première édition dans des bucs la
première édition dans des buts est
programmée à partir de ce mardi 9
novembre donc c'est sur la thématique
des rencontres sur la thématique du
handicap c'est notre interview express
[Musique]
l'objectif c'est vraiment de
sensibiliser beaucoup de public c'est de
sensibiliser
les élus les personnes qui travaillent
la mairie le public plus quoi les
enfants les personnes qui sont pas au
courant et puis aussi les personnes qui
vivent cette situation de handicap soit
puisqu'elles sont tels même en situation
de handicap ou soit puisqu'elles sont
tes dents et il y en a vraiment beaucoup
donc c'était pour que les gens soient
davantage sensibilisés et éventuellement
qu'ils veuillent pourquoi pas s'engager
à deux évènements mardi le mardi soir
17h on a une conférence sur l'épilepsie
et comment est ce que on accompagne
surtout les enfants ou les personnes qui
souffrent d'épilepsie dans les écoles
dans la situation sociale donc on a ça
on a aussi mardi matin et ça sent repris
le dimanche lors du grand week end un
théâtre forum alors le sujet du théâtre
forum c'est comment insérer ces
personnes qui sont en situation
d'handicap dans le milieu professionnel
le 13 samedi on va passer le film young
pas si en angleterre de buc à 20h30 on a
aussi le dimanche donc c'est le dimanche
qui la grande journée une partie aussi
au gymnase où il y aura des associations
sportives et l'autre qui vont présenter
et puis le dimanche je me permets
puisque je prends le document j'ai pas
tout en tête mais ils vont vivre des
expositions des animations
des conférences des débats en début donc
à partir de ce mardi 9 novembre à buc et
ça se poursuit jusqu'au week-end
prochain lé 13 et 14 novembre oui parce
que bixente le sais tu ce week-end on
donne des idées de sorties pour le
week-end qui nous concerne mais aussi le
week-end d'après en l'occurrence le je
le disais c'est le week-end des 13 et 14
novembre avec pour terminer cette
émission de la musique le retour d'un
fameux festival de la vallée de seine
exactement c'est la 22e édition de
festival blues sur seine de nombreux
concerts auront lieu du 12 au 27
novembre parmi les têtes d'affiché jean
jacques milteau un des monuments de
l'harmonica en france le chanteur
guitariste eric macé quo également pour
revisiter certains classiques du jazz du
blues de la sole ou encore laura cox on
refuse aux styles très variés pour la
programmation elle est répartie sur de
nombreuses villes du coup du val de
seine mantes-la-jolie magnanville lime
et aubergenville andrésy et en légende
et j'en passe pour cible est une commune
ou un artiste en particulier rendez vous
sur le site internet du festival quant
aux tarifs ils varient selon les
concerts à noter cependant que le pass
illimité pour avoir accès à tous est
fixé à 95 euros merci bixente pour
toutes ces idées on vous retrouve ou ce
week-end vous ce weekend peut-être du
côté de la course royal j'ai fait
quelques footings peut-être que je me
joindrai à vous pour cette course royal
effectivement qui est au programme 2 du
parc du château de versailles jusqu'à
fontenay-le-fleury merci pour toutes ces
idées c'est déjà est la fin de ce set 8
week-end merci est d'avoir été avec nous
ne manquez pas lundi sur tv 60,18 le
retour du journal de la rédaction et 10
il a passé un très bon week end sur tv
[Musique]
tous